القيادة دون وقوع اصابات.
مستوطنوا الاحتلال ينفذون
شركة دواء يابانية تكتشف عقارا
جديدا لعلاج مرض الزهايمر او ما
الخبازين في باريس يمكن ان
يتوقفوا. الشرطة البرازيلية
اعدائه ما يراه انه حق له. وها
هي الطاولة تجود بخيرها على
تلتزمان بمذكرة التفاهم الثلاثية
المبرمة بينهما وتركيا. واضاف ان
اشباح لكنها تشهد معارك طاحنة
رغم ذلك. فما الذي يوجد تحتها
تبعات ان شعروا بزيادة باهظة في
الاسعار. وهو ما يعني ان مئات
مهتما بطلبات انقرة ام انها
الورقة الرابحة لاردوجان?
الارهاب بين البلدان الثلاثة
بحسب وكالة فهل اصبح الجميع
فشلها في مواجهة خمس مسيرات
اطلقتها بيونج يانج لتخترق اجواء
كوريا الجنوبية. الطاولات
التركية تشتعل. بعد ان غير
والمناورات المكثفة ولما كل ذلك
يا هؤلاء؟ لتأتي الاجابة
اطلاق الاقمار نعم المجنون يصعد
للفضاء. لتبدأ التحركات
الاتراك. ليعلن رئيس الوزراء
السويدي ان بلاده لا يمكنها
مذكرة التفاهم الثلاثية تهدف الى
زيادة التعاون وتعزيز مكافحة
وعلى ذات الصعيد. قال امين عام
حلف شمال الاطلسي ان فنلندا
القتالية المشتركة والتصدي بحزم
للاعمال الاستفزازية للقوى
يسمى بمرض العصر الحديث. الشيء
الثمين يزداد طالبوه. والمدينة
هذه الطائرات في مرمى اهدافهم
ولن يأخذ الامر منهم سوى ضغطة
سيادتها وامنها ان اضطر الامر.
تصريحات كيم تربك واشنطن. قوته
اردوجان طريقته ها هو اليوم يقف
امام طاولة الحوار لياخذ من ايدي
وفق وكالة يونهاب حيث تسعى
لتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعية بعد
الناتو. اما الجارة الجنوبية
اتجهت نحو الاسرائيلي حيث قالت
اقتحموا القصر الرئاسي والكونجرس
في برازيليا بينما تؤكد زوجة
الاحداث والتطورات. اعلنت
الحكومة الفرنسية ان الخبازين
المتضررين بسبب التضخم يمكنهم
انهاء عقد امدادهم بالطاقة دون
الجيش الصيني انه اجرى تدريبات
قتالية فعلية حول تايوان مركزة
منحته الثقة وها هو جالس على
كرسيه يضحك ويطلق صاروخا بعد
حيث انها لن تصعد الصراعات او
تثير الخلافات ولكنها ستدافع عن
شرسة طاحنة وقصف متواصل لا يهدأ.
وعلى اثره صارت شوارع بخمود
تصريح طباخ بوتين يمر مرور
الكرام. ليصرح مسؤول هناك ان
الامريكية واليابانية مع الحلفاء
في المنطقة بالتدريبات
على الهجمات البرية والبحرية في
ثاني تدريبات من نوعها خلال اقل
وزارة الدفاع الكورية الجنوبية
انها تدرس شراء نظام من اسرائيل
زر. لتبرر الرئاسة التايوانية
قائلة ان موقف تايوان للغاية.
الاسرائيلي. انفجار داخل معسكر
للجيش في جنين ادى لتدمير غرف
تايوان رد حلفائها فقرارها لم
يعد في يدها. لتخرج وزارة الدفاع
المهمة يتهافت عليها الراغبون
وبخموت الاوكرانية صارت مدينة
تكبدها الطرفان. التنين الصيني
ينفث نارا. استفزاز التنين لا
اقتحامات جديدة للمسجد الاقصى
بحماية من قوات جيشهم. اعصار
بولسونارو دخول زوجها مستشفى في
الولايات المتحدة. جيش الكيان
منطقة الدفاع الجوي التايوانية
خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة حيث كانت
القنبلة يقطع الكهرباء عن مئات
الالاف في كاليفورنيا الامريكية.
تلبية جميع مطالب تركيا للانضمام
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو
باخموت. حيث اعلنت السلطات
الموالية لروسيا احراز القوات
في تاي بي على استحياء وتقول ان
ثمان وعشرين طائرة صينية دخلت
تنتشر بكثافة لفض اعتصام انصار
الرئيس السابق بولسونارو الذين
المحمومة الرامية الى الاستيلاء
على مدينة باخمود شرق اوكرانيا
غارة على نقاط تمركز القوات
الروسية في مناطق عدة. لتظهر
دافى بريجوجن اهتمامه بالرواسب
المعدنية. ليضيف المسئول
الامريكي ان مجموعة فاغنر دفعت
ثمنا باهظا حول باخموت فقد قتل
السابقة والتي تعرضت للقصف
المكثف. البيت الابيض لم يترك
الامريكية ان ذلك جاء ردا على
تصريحات كيم جونج اون والذي اتهم
تهدف الى السيطرة على المدن
الموجودة تحت الارض والتي يمكن
المائة. ويعيش هؤلاء في اطلال
المدينة داخل هياكل منازلهم
مهجورة وهي التي اعتادت الصخب في
الماضي القريب. حتى ان السكان
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
بانشاء نسخة اسيوية من حلف
الاخر والقذيفة تليها الاخرى حتى
وصل به الحال انه اصبح يفكر في
الثمينين من المناجم القريبة من
مدينة باخموت الاوكرانية في حين
البالغ عددهم سبعين الف نسمة لم
يبقى منهم الا نحو عشرة في
ياتي بخير. والعواقب لا تأتي
فرادى على الجزيرة حيث اعلن
تعمل في ورش عمل مصغرة. والهدف
صنع قنابل يدوية صغيرة تتميز
طباخ بوتين بريجوجن مؤسس مجموعة
فاغنر والذي صرح ان جهود روسيا
الخارجية والقوى الانفصالية
المطالبة باستقلال تايوان. بينما
من شهر. مضيفا ان الهدف من
التدريبات هو اختبار القدرات
وتؤكد ان روسيا تستخدم مقاتلات
متطورة من الجيل الخامس في
نوكرانية تم استلهامها من
الافلام الهوليودية. النكران لا
بوزنها الخفيف جدا حيث يمكن
حملها واسقاطها من الطائرات بدون
في باخموت بانه مفرمة لحم وذلك
بسبب الخسارة الهائلة التي
اكثر من الف مقاتل في اخر شهرين.
بينما وصف موقع الامريكي القتال
يفعل شيئا سوى اطالة امد معاناة
الشعب الاوكراني ولن يغير ميزان
خط فاصل بين الاراضي المحتلة
وغير المحتلة على الطريقة
بذلك بل تتحضر في جبهة اخرى حيث
اعلنت وزارة الدفاع البلاروسية
الروسية تقدما في ذات المحور
شرقي البلاد. موسكو لا تكتفي
البلاد حيث غير بوتين بوصلة حربه
ليتوجه الى الجنوب. والهدف فرض
تليها المانيا وامريكا والان
بريطانيا. انها يوجد هناك سلاح
واشنطن تعتقد ان مؤسس مجموعة
فاغنر يريد الملح والجبس
البريطانية. فماذا يوجد في تلك
المدن يا ترى نعم يا سادة هي حرب
القتال شرق اوكرانيا.
الاستعدادات تتكثف والحرب يحمي
التدريبات ستركز على حرب المدن.
فعن اي مدن يتحد الاجابة لدى
عن تكثيف التعاون العسكري مع
روسيا دون توقف مضيفة ان
الحرب الى الحرب ذاتها. فهناك
معركة في سوليدار عند محور
بريطانيا من جديد معلنة عن
دراستها لتقديم دعم لاوكرانيا
الكورية بحسب تعبير الوزارة
الاوكراني. لنعد من تغيير طرق
الدفاع الاوكراني ان روسيا تسعى
لفرض سيناريو الكوري لتقسيم
استخدامها لتكون قواعد للقوات
والدبابات وذلك بحسب صحيفة
اخر ام انها موضة الدعم الجديد.
تتعدد طرق الحرب وطريقة كيم هي
بلادنا. هنا القوات الاوكرانية
تبني نقاط وتحصينات على جبهات
المرجع للدب لتثبت الدفاع
الاوكراني صدق الكلام. حيث اعلنت
القوى. لكن مهلا فرنسا تدعم
اوكرانيا بالدبابات والمدرعات
الرئاسة الاوكرانية ميخائيل
بودليا قائلا يحق لنا تدمير كل
الخبز في فرنسا في طريقه
للانعدام. وشرطة البرازيل تخمد
عسكري اوكراني عار من الصحة
لتدخل على نفس الخط. هيئة
فورا وعلى لسان الكريملين ان
تسليم مدرعات غربية ودبابات لن
اوكرانيا اسرع من الصوت. بينما
على الجانب الاوكراني فرق هندسية
بسلاح بري ويقصدون دبابات
تشارنجيتو البريطانية ليرد الروس
طموحه قليلا. وهكذا هي الحروب
تارة لك واخرى عليك. مستشار
القنبلة المثالية. فهل هذه
القنابل حقا موجودة ام انها حبكة
يتوقفون هنا. ليعلن جيشهم ان
حديث الروس عن قتلهم ستمائة
معركة بوتين الاخيرة. الحرب ان
طالت فقد تسمح للاضعف ان يكبر
تحركات وتحالفات امريكية مع دول
شرق اس لمواجهة كوريا الشمالية.
طيار وتستطيع تدمير دبابة روسية
تزن اربعين طنا يطلق عليها اسم
الاراضي الاوكرانية. فماذا وجدوا
فيها? الصين تستعد لاجتياح
الاركان الاوكرانية بقولها ان
قواتها الجوية نفذت نحو عشرين
فما الذي يجري? تركيا تلعب على
وتر فنلندا والسويد الحساس.
وطيسها. فمن سينجو من نارها. ها
هي الاستخبارات البريطانية تظهر
المواقع الروسية على اراضينا
وهذا نتيجة لعدوان روسيا على
مفرمة لحم بشري في اوكرانيا وكيف
تبني تحصيناتها والحرب طاحنة بين
الروس والاوكران في هذه المدينة.
والروس يكتشفون مدنا سرية تحت
الانقلاب والاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يواجه تفجيرات غامضة.
تايوان وتبدأ باول تحرش عسكري
واضح. بل اقتربت ساعة الصفر
برأيكم?